Alright, and just to make sure this epsilon exhaustion conpcet
is clear, let's actually use it in a quiz. So,
here's our example from before. We've got our target concept,
which is X or, we've got our training data which is
these, with the things that are in the green boxes
here, 0 0 output 0 1 0 output 1. And
this time, I'll actually write down a distribtiuon D that gives
the. Probability of drawing each of these different input examples.
All right? So now what we'd like to do is find an epsilon such
that that this training set that we've
gotten has epsilon exhausted the version space.
>> Okay. I got it. I think I got that.
>> You think you, you think you can work that one through?
>> Yeah.
>> Anything else that we'd have to tell you? Remember
again that These are the hypothesis in the hypothesis set.
>> huh. Yeah. Yeah. I got it.
>> Alright. Let's, let's,
let's see what you got.
>> Okay.